oh thanks so much for coming thanks for
having me we do love it when you stop by
why because you're a big star
kid you're going places see okay well it
appears i am yeah you got moxie
you heard the news the news yes yes
there's going to be another show called
mary and rhoda
that's right you're doing this yeah this
is exciting news
it really is i'm so thrilled about this
and we have rosie o'donnell to thank for
it because valerie and i were
on the show we were sitting together on
the couch and it just the chemistry was
there i knew when she
wanted me to say something i knew when
to lay out and she did too
and as we were walking out to our cars
afterwards
almost simon simultaneously we said we
ought to do this again
and so we're going to so so that's what
the nice thing about rosie is she brings
people together
she does andy and i we divide them
if you guys had come on this show first
you'd have left fighting
we're never working together again
what's even nicer is she doesn't take a
percentage oh that's very nice i demand
a percentage
aha anything that you do in show
business after your appearance on this
show i get 40
all right that seems reasonable yeah
it's very reasonable
did you uh did you have a nice
thanksgiving well thank you yes we did
do you uh do you get excited about like
the thanksgiving day balloons that kind
of thing or is it old hat to you
oh no i do i like it a lot and and
what's interesting
there we now live across the park with
the grown-ups on the east side
but when we lived right on central park
west it was so much fun
because on thanksgiving day there i'd be
getting dressed and all of a sudden
snoopy is looking in on me and it made
me very uneasy he's a latch
yes but i found myself timing it so that
i would be getting dressed
every year just as hoping for superman
or one of the others uh-huh you just
wanted to have someone come by
yeah a lot of activity in that window
one time they were
cleaning the building and uh there were
two guys on scaffolding
and they looked inside and and the guy
said
hey look look it's and the guy said the
other guy said yes it's what's her name
she used to be on the rota show
[Laughter]
and you shoved them both off exactly and
they fell to their deaths
exactly uh do you on on thanksgiving
because you're a pretty strict
vegetarian what do you do
you don't have a turkey in the house we
spare the turkey yeah you actually
invite a turkey there and
and tell him you get to live because of
me how does it work you know there are a
lot of wild turkeys on our property up
in uh
in duchess and um yes what we do is not
go out and shoot one of them
well no one really does that except jed
clampett does it but
everyone else goes to the supermarket
yeah but somebody does something to
those birds to get them on your plate
and that's the part i can't stand
so we have all the other stuff you know
like the candied yams and the mashed
potatoes and the
pearled onions and all of that and do
you mash them into the shape of a turkey
so they people have a turkey it has to
be some there has to be a turkey shape
in there
that's what i believe food comes into
play really a
a tofu very good to mold you might want
to move this my i'm just got a signal
back here for the your necklace
is uh rubbing up against your mic and i
hate to tell you what's happening with
me and the battery maybe i could
actually we plan on that one yeah
do you want me to maybe i should wear
the necklace for a bit is it a problem
or are we okay
i'll just move this over i'll just move
this over here
i'll just move this over here i'm
touching harry tell her more
um liked being touched yeah so uh
you uh you you mentioned you live on
this farm yeah in the past when you've
been on the program you say that you're
around the animals so much you do
impressions of them
you've done some great impressions for
us now i do yeah yes
[Laughter]
any new impressions any new impressions
of animals
i've been working on um the horse call
because we have five horses and not one
of them ever pays attention to me
they give me great rides but they just
are i don't know
they're they're autistic right they
don't want to have any kind of
very hard to get an autistic horse yeah
it is but i did it
so anyway i try to reach them by going
[Applause]
that was frightening for me
that was very good does that help or do
they become afraid
they run they run away from me i do one
animal i do a lizard that's the only one
i do
okay oh yes
very good you know what else that's uh
that's also my sam
donaldson but uh or red skeleton or red
skelton yeah
that's the only one i do though well i
specialize it's a niche
yes that i'm working on yes um i
understand and correct me if i'm wrong
because it's so strange you have this
this uh you know very nice image that
you once stalked a celebrity
and you yourself mary tyler moore once
stalked a celebrity when i was in high
school and i went to a catholic girls
high school so there wasn't any
opportunity for real male female contact
my friends and i fantasized about
someday meeting uh marlon brando
and uh we would write these scenarios
about how we would meet and what he
would say and what we would do and how
he would finally
find each other entwined and
one year we all piled in to my friend
didi sawoya's
desoto brown de soto and we drove up
laurel canyon because we had just found
out where he lived
and we waited there every weekend every
friday every saturday night
waiting for him to come out and we never
saw him uh
to our knowledge we were about to give
it up we were about to just you know go
home and
spend normal weekends when one evening a
guy with a
gray hair and a limp and a mustache came
out
and we knew that it was brando
he got in a car was he wearing a
disguise he must have been wearing a
discovery no that was brandon
yes he was wearing a disguise well i
thought maybe you were talking so long
this was like two years ago oh yeah yeah
no no no no no no so we still outside
still a desoto
a 70 year old marlon brando leaves
he was the best looking thing ever god
he was gorgeous in his youth
anyway we followed him down mulholland
drive until we got to coldwater canyon
and there was i think there still is a
kind of a wide
sort of parking area and he pulled in
and he beckoned for us to
to follow and he got out of the car and
started walking
to us looking straight at us and
i know he was looking at me
[Laughter]
and the moustache was gone in the wig
and the limp was gone and he came over
and he said
now surely you girls could find
something better to do up here on
mulholland drive
no more you go on get away from me
and he sauntered back into his car and
drove off
well it took me about a year to take a
full
breath again after that experience and
all
the kids yeah yeah yeah but um
did you ever see them later on yeah yeah
years uh
years later long after i had done the
dick van dyke show and we
were already doing the mary tyler moore
show and i was introduced to him
in the vip lounge at the airport and he
was sitting
kind of sitting on his spine reading a
magazine and somebody said
mr brando i'd like you to meet miss
moore and he looked up and kind of
grunted his acknowledgement and
that was bad enough but when we got onto
the plane we'd been in flight for about
a half hour he came over to me and said
i'm sorry i didn't realize who you were
now that disappointed me even further
but the worst part was that he didn't
remember me from mulholland drive
did you say it was me and the desoto oh
no i wasn't gonna get
down on my knees and grubble his
attention but marlon
if you're out there oh he watches you're
watching he watches regularly he's
eating haagen-dazs right now and
watching the show
you may want to cut back on that
sweetheart no he's happier this way
um i have to mention i'll just mention
one more time that
of course you and and and uh valerie
harper are reuniting
what's the show going to be called it's
going to be called marion rhoda
and it will be those two beloved
characters uh
living today in their late 50s in new
york and they will each have a daughter
in their early 20s mine i named rhoda
and she named her as mary
so the title marion rhoda is quadro
this was just a cut down on confusion
okay
right and uh of course i also want to
mention november is national
diabetes awareness month thank you for
mentioning yes no problem all right
always a thrill when you come by thank
you so much
tyler moore everybody